I will pu...
(Pewds gasp)
Please god...
(Jesus music)
I miss Sweden...
I miss my roots...
Take me back...
To where I belong...
(Poods experiences enlightenment)
Where am I?
( Sniffing... )
Nicely polished..
Minimalistic style kitchen!
Could this...
Could this be...?
I am IN... IKEA!!!
YESSS!
Ohhh!
This stove is amazing...
Oh my God!
Aww this is so goo-..
(Wtf Poods..)
This is so good!
Oh.. what happens if I click on this?
OHHHHHHHH!
Yeesss!
I'm flying through the sky! (Seriously, wtf)
On Edgar as a dragon!
(Orgasmic noise)
Take me..
Take me to Nangiala!
Matthew..
(????)
Sponser eagle!
Alright you gotta chair?
Yep!
You do that fucking shit again!
I swear to God!
Come here!
I hear you laughing you bitch!
Oh wowwwww!
Woah! There's a dragon!
Wow!
Blastin' it.
Woah!
This is fucking awesome.
Alright, I'm going back in time guys!
Holy shit that's a big fish.
The Leedsichthys was the largest bony fish to have ever lived.
Yeah.
You think I care?
The Pliosaurus is one creature you definitely-..
This is super LAME!
Killll meeeee!
KILLLL MEEEEEEEEE!
(Renai Circulation remix plays)
Woah what the fuck is this.
OMG I'm on a bed.
Oooo.. That's a nice bed.
Where am I?
What is this place?
Woah that's creepy.
This is actually really scaaaaary and weird. I don't like it.
What is this??
What is thiss??
There's a demon here!
There's a demon somewhere!
Hello?
This is too sexual again I'm sorry.
Woah there's some flickering lights over there.
Hello?
OMG Someone's coming up!
I know Kung...
Fucking Fu!
I will pu...
(Poods dies)
Pfffff...
Did I break them?
Jesus Christ!
Did I throw them at yo-?
I'll put on this safety straps.
There's a stupid Teddy Bear.
You have to look at the lights.
The flickering lights.
Oh..
(Speaking Swedish) Fuck!
Come on was that it?
I mean that was...
That was it..
I can make a better game with my fuckin' mom!
In pink.
(Renai Circulation remix again)
What is this?
I just dance?
Is that it?
There's no music!
Ohhh!
(Speaking Swedish) Fucking...
What the fuck is wrong-..
Why am I a fucking dragon?!
WHAT!
THE!
FUCK!
IS!
THIIIIS?!
Wait...
Is this some kinda furry trap???
I'm not into your furry bullshit.
Now my friend.
You can play with the music!
OOOOOOHHHHHHH!
Thank you dragonnn!!
For giving meee!
Dancing powerrrrrs!!
(Electric music)
Dance fo the dragon!!
DANCEEE!
FUCK!
JEA!!
Fuck yea I'll get your balls dragon.
(Wtf Pewds...)
I'll keep shooting balls.
I look so fucking cool right now.
Bah bah bah bah buhhh.. buh buh!
(brrooo, bruu, bruu bruu bruu bruu...)
PLUG ME IN BRO!!!
I'M ON A FUCKING ROOOLLL!!!
This is the highest porn of my life!
Can't catch all the balls...
I don't kn-
How much more...
I can do...
Where am I?
Where am I??
(Orgasm)
Don't look at me.
Don't look at me..
Don't look.. at me..
It's not fucking over YETT!
Awe man I'm killing it.
I ain't neva stoppin' playing this gamee!
Screw Marzia!
Screw my YouTube channel!
FUCK THE WHOLE WORLD!!!
VR-...
NOOO!!
I NEED TO START DANCING!!!
NOOO!!!!
LET GO OF ME!!!
(Inaudible Swedish)
Let go of me!!!!
LETTT GO OF ME!
(More Inaudible Swedish)
PIECE OF SHIT!
(Girly scream)
You have to live...
We have Olympia!
You can't live that forever.
You can't be a dragon.
Thank you!
THAT WAS PATHETIC!
Be responsible with VR.
You never know what's gonna happen.
Don't do-.. do drugs.
Do alcohol.
But don't do VR.
This has been poodiepie.
I approve this message.
Brofist.